OUT OF CALIFORNIA AS WE FOLLOW
THAT BREAKING NEWS THERE.
A LOT OF NEWS HERE IN
WASHINGTON.
POLITICAL NEWS.
WE START AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
WHERE AN INCREASING BLUSTER FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP ABOUT A CARAVAN
OF AROUND 1000-1500 IMMIGRANTS
FROM CENTRAL AMERICA.
THE GROUP TRAVELING THROUGH
MEXICO TOWARD THE U.S. BORDER
AND THE PRESIDENT SAYS IT MUST
BE STOPPED.
HE'S CONSIDERING USING THE U.S.
MILITARY, HE SAYS, ALONG THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, TO DO IT.
THIS OCCURS AS NEW CONCERNS GROW
ABOUT U.S. TROOP COMMITMENT IN
SYRIA AND A POSSIBLE TRADE WAR
WITH CHINA.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS STARTS US OFF
TONIGHT FROM THE NORTH LAWN ON
THE POLITICS NEWS.
JOHN?
>> BRET, GOOD EVENING TO YOU.
PRESIDENT TRUMP INSIST THAT THE
BEST WAY TO SECURE OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER IS WITH A MASSIVE
WALL.
IN THE ABSENCE OF A WALL,
PRESIDENT TRUMP TODAY FLOATED
ANOTHER CONTROVERSIAL IDEA.
>> OKAY, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP GAVE NO
DETAILS OR WOULD SAY IF U.S.
TROOPS WOULD BE INVOLVED.
THE MEETING WITH BALTIC LEADER
TODAY, HE REVEALED HE
WANTS THE U.S. MILITARY GUARDING
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> SPEAKING WITH GENERAL MATTIS,
WILL BE DOING THINGS MILITARY
ALL, UNTIL WE CAN HAVE A WALL
AND PROPER SECURITY, WE'LL
BE GUARDING OUR BORDER WITH THE
MILITARY.
THAT'S A BIG STEP.
WE REALLY HAVEN'T DONE THAT
BEFORE.
>> OFFICIALS SAY THE WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL'S OFFICE HAS BEEN
LOOKING INTO THE LEGAL ASPECTS
OF PUTTING THE MILITARY ALONG
THE BORDER.
THE NATIONAL GUARD HAS BEEN USED
SEVERAL TIMES TO ASSIST THE
BORDER PATROL AND IN THE EARLY
'90s, A MILITARY JOINT
TASK FORCE WAS ON THE BORDER TO
COUNTER NARCOTICS AND
COUNTERTERRORISM.
A PLAN HAS YET TO BE FORMULATED,
JUST THE IDEA DREW A SHARP
RESPONSE FROM FORMER MEXICO
PRESIDENT FOR GENT A FOX, WHO
TWEETED, "DEMILITARIZED
SOUTHERN BORDER TO PROVOKE MORE
HATE AND DISTANCE AND FURTHER
OUR NATIONS.
SOMEONE HAS TO TALK SOME SENSE
INTO HIM.
HE'S CAUSING A GREATER
CONFLICT."
PRESIDENT TRUMP CLAIMED VICTORY
TODAY IN HIS PUBLIC PRESSURE
TWITTER CAMPAIGN TO HAVE MEXICO
STOP THE CARAVAN OF CENTRAL
AMERICAN MIGRANTS TRAVELING TO
THE U.S. BORDER.
THE PRESIDENT HAD GONE SO FAR AS
TO THREATEN NAFTA IF MEXICO
DIDN'T DO SOMETHING.
>> I TOLD MEXICO VERY STRONGLY,
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THESE CARAVANS.
AND THEY HAVE TO DO IT.
OTHERWISE I'M NOT GOING TO DO
THE NAFTA DEAL.
NAFTA HAS BEEN FANTASTIC FOR
MEXICO, BAD FOR US.
>> THE GROUP THAT ORGANIZED THE
CARAVAN, PEOPLE WITHOUT BORDERS,
CRITICIZED THE PRESIDENT FOR
DEMONIZING AT AN ANNUAL EVENT
THEY CLAIM IS A HUMANITARIAN
MISSION.
>> Translator: MIGRANTS SHOULD
NOT BE ABANDONED BECAUSE OF SOME
TWEETS AND POLITICAL HATE.
IT IS VERY CHARACTERISTIC OF
DONALD TRUMP TO GOVERN VIA TWEET
DONALD TRUMP TO GOVERN VIA TWEE
TWEET.
>> WHILE PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
SEEKING AN EXPANDED ROLE FOR THE
MILITARY AND DEFENDING THE
BORDER, HE IS LOOKING AT THE
SHRINKING THE U.S. PROFILE IN
SYRIA.
>> IT'S TIME.
IT'S TIME.
WE WERE VERY SUCCESSFUL AGAINST
ISIS, WE'LL BE SUCCESSFUL
AGAINST ANYBODY MILITARILY.
BUT SOMETIMES IT'S TIME TO COME
BACK HOME.
AND WE ARE THINKING ABOUT THAT
VERY SERIOUSLY.
>> BUT EVEN THE PRESIDENT'S OWN
ADVISORS SAY THE U.S. NEEDS TO
STAY IN SYRIA FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE.
>> WE ARE IN SYRIA TO FIGHT
ISIS, THAT IS OUR MISSION.
OUR MISSION IS NOT OVER.
WE ARE GOING TO COMPLETE THAT
MISSION.
>> EXPERTS WORRY A U.S. PULLOUT
COULD LEAD TO A RESURGENCE OF
VICES AND REMOVE A COUNTERWEIGHT
TO RUSSIAN INFLUENCE IN SYRIA.
TODAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ASKED
ABOUT HIS RELATIONSHIP WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN, WHETHER HE SAW
HIM AS AN ENEMY OR FRIEND.
>> I THINK I COULD HAVE A VERY
GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH RUSSIA.
AND WITH PRESIDENT PUTIN, AND
DIVIDED, THAT WOULD BE A GREAT
THING.
AND THERE'S ALSO A GREAT
POSSIBILITY THAT WON'T HAPPEN.
WHO KNOWS.
>> THE PRESIDENT DISMISSED THE
NOTION HE IS NOT TOUGH ON
RUSSIA.
POINTING TO HIS RECENT ORDER TO
EXPEL A 60 RUSSIAN DIPLOMATS IN
THE U.S.
>> SO THERE ARE MANY THINGS THAT
I'VE DONE, NOT ONLY THE 60
DIPLOMATS, GERMANY DID FOUR,
FRANCE DID FOUR.
WE DID 60.
THERE IS NOBODY BEEN TOUGHER ON
RUSSIA.
>> WHETHER U.S. TROOPS SHOULD
STAY IN SYRIA, PRESIDENT TRUMP
REVEALED THAT IN HIS MEETINGS
WITH THE SAUDI CANON, CROWN
PRINCE, MOHAMMED BIN SALMAN,
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOLD HIM OF
SAUDI ARABIA WANTS U.S. TROOPS
TO STAY IN SYRIA TO STABILIZE
THE SITUATION, MAYBE THEY SHOULD
PICK UP THE TAB.